Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie this will be my full Lord
of the Rings the Rings of Power episode
8 finale video there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and references we finally got some of our
really big answers like we finally found out
who Sauron really is we found out what's going
on with Meteor Man so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will do videos
for season two when it gets here they're in the
middle of making it right now but the way they
talk about it they won't be ready to release it
to like 2024 so it's going to be a while before it
comes out careful for spoilers for the episode if
you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at the
beginning and work our way through shop by shot
talking about Easter eggs WTF moments as we go
along the episode was titled alloyed which is a
reference to them using the me thrill with the new
superforge and binding different Metals together
like the medals from galadriel's dagger the gold
and the silver from valonor because the minerals
from valinor were way more pure than the ones from
Middle Earth making the Elven rings of power much
more powerful than the other rings of power some
of this is Canon from the books and some of this
is them adding some stuff to the Canon like I
don't think there's any references to them using
galadriel's brother's dagger to create the Elven
rings of power like there's no real details on
that so this is something that they added to the
show and the whole idea with galadriel's character
is that much later in the timeline like during the
events of the Peter Jackson movies in the third
age she's way less warlike and she spends most of
her time with her husband trying to protect their
city so I think the idea with her getting rid
of the Dagger by sacrificing it like they say
true creation requires sacrifice sacrificing
her dagger is basically like her saying that
she's going to become less warlike in the future
like she's laying down arms pursuing a less dark
path because that was the path that was driving
her closer to Sauron but the actual opening scene
is a meteor man in the harflets continuing their
journey to Mordor through the Greenwood that's
called Aaron Galen like they have the title up
on screen here the Greenwood is basically what
will eventually turn into mirkwood later in the
timeline during the events of The Hobbit movies
sauron's Power basically turned it evil like
he darkened the area the same way that morgoth
did with his power Sauron during the episode even
makes a lot of references to his Untold backstory
with morgoth like in a way that you don't hear
about in the books but the whole idea here with
the women is that we find out these female Mages
are from roon they are followers of morgoth and
Sauron technically their followers of morgoth and
Sauron is sort of like the next best person who's
available to them and they're just resolving the
whole story line with him trying to decide who he
is not being totally sure and they explain later
in the episode too that when he landed on Middle
Earth he didn't have all of his memories like
they slowly came back to him as did his true power
which is also meant to be a parallel for what
happened with Sauron but the whole idea is the
women confused the signs and believe that he is
Sauron when really he is a mayor just like Sauron
is like they're both from the same group of angels
basically only Meteor Man winds up being one of
the blue Wizards now he specifically calls out the
Ishtar the istari that's the group that Gandalf
comes from the Saruman the other Wizards come
from but there are a couple other references they
make specifically during their conversations when
they're talking about roon that I think refers to
the blue Wizards which I think this guy is going
to wind up being because the books don't really go
into great detail about the blue Wizards whereas
the Wizards that we MO mostly know of like Gandalf
zaromon radagast all those people don't show up
till the third age obviously the other side of
this is the reveal that Halbrand is really been
Sauron this whole time don't worry I will talk
all about that because it basically confirms all
of our theories from the first couple of episodes
like I was actually surprised like wait a minute
you mean we were right originally because there
were so many misdirects about who Halbrand was
we were all kind of wondering how much trickery
they were trying to pull with us like is the show
just trying to mislead us and give us false clues
about who he really is what they revealed is that
the game that they were playing was much simpler
like they weren't trying to trick us as much as
we thought they were so when you go back and you
re-watch the series now knowing who everybody
really is it'll recontextualize all of Hal bran
scenes like it'll make way more sense then we
see Galadriel riding with the wounded Halbrand
to celebrimbor City Oregan and the whole idea is
that his power has been diminished so much that
it is possible to wound him in this way don't
worry I'll explain how the mayor's Powers work
and how you can actually destroy their physical
body but you can't really kill their soul like
what happens to Sauron after they destroy the One
Ring of Power if it might seem like he's permitted
at that time but it's actually a little bit more
complicated than that but all these early scenes
with the elves are meant to set up them creating
the rings of power like they haven't quite got
the idea yet and the whole idea is that Halbrand
tries to trick them in a tar style Lord of gifts
he kind of coaches Celebrimbor into thinking that
the idea was his the whole time like early on Hal
bran shows up at Celebrimbor 's Forge pretending
like he was looking for Galadriel but really this
is him just manipulating Celebrimbor with flattery
orchestrating things so that Celebrimbor thinks
that this was all his idea the whole time even
though Galadriel eventually finds out what's up
with him when he references the master smith he
apprentices to speaking of Celebrimbor's works
he's talking about the Valar Aule the same one
who created the dwarves sauron's whole specialty
was in crafting things that's how he came up
with the idea for the rings of power because
he learned it from Aule who is also referred to
as the Smith we see the three gemstones that they
used to create the three Elven rings of power
now these are just like regular gemstones the
red one is called Narya that's the red ring of
fire eventually it's worn by by Gandalf later in
the timeline during the events of the Lord of the
Rings movies and he takes it with him on the boat
back to valinor the first wearer winds up being
Gil Galad like they give it to him first then it
goes to kurdan the shipwright who's going to be a
character during season two and then it passes to
Gandalf nenya is the white one here it's the Ring
of water it's galadriel's ring she also wears it
all the way to the end of Return of the King and
takes it back to valinor with him and the blue one
is Villa the blue ring of air eventually elrond
winds up becoming its bear and he also takes it
with them back to valenor so like all the Elven
rings of power will eventually go back to valenor
at the end of Return of the King the whole idea
here is that they were never touched by sauron's
hands though so they're not bound to the One Ring
of Power which is why when Sauron creates the One
Ring of Power like they tease at the end of
the episode like he's staring at Mount Doom
like ah gonna create some more Rings it doesn't
hurt Galadriel or the other bearers of the Elven
rings but once they do destroy the one ring it
does diminish the power of the Elven rings of
power one of the other power upgrades that they
give to the Elven rings that are different from
the other rings of power that they give to the
humans and the dwarves is the actual mithril and
the ore from validor like the whole idea is that
it's going to be more powerful than the or Sauron
will use to create the other rings of power is
the gold and silver from galadriel's brother's
dagger but also the meath rail which contains the
light of a silmaril which is basically the light
from the two trees in the Lambs so they want to
show you fundamentally that the Elven rings are
very different from the other rings of power one
of their abilities like a lot of the other Rings
is to basically prolong life to preserve things
they do have some other power so Narnia also
has the power to inspire others to stand strong
against evil and tyranny to resist domination and
despair in other words to give hope where it was
needed you hear Gandalf giving a lot of speeches
to the fellowship later in the timeline about
this galadriel's ring nenya gave her the power to
protect and preserve things later in the timeline
when she founds the city of lothlorian there's a
lot of references to her using the power of the
Ring to hide it from Sauron there are a lot of
references to the other powers of villa the Ring
of air but a lot of people believe that it's used
to heal people for the most part the power of
the other rings of power like the Lesser rings
that are given to men given to dwarves even the
one ring of power are basically to preserve and
prolong life because they contain a fraction of
sauron's power like he pours his power into the
one ring it's kind of like a horcrux for him so
the extra power upgrade that it gives to people
that wear those lesser Rings is basically them
just wielding a portion of sauron's power and
that's also what creates the connection between
those rings in the one ring of power in sauron's
life force which allows him to dominate the will
of anyone who wears the Rings but when we're still
with Meteor Man the women talk about taking him
to ruin the Far Land east of Mordor they teased
that earlier this season we didn't really explore
that during the Peter Jackson movies like you see
some of the people from roon hear but that's about
it they eventually align with Mordor and when they
call the constellation that he's been looking at
this whole time the hermit's Hat that's another
reference to the writers basically saying that
he's one of the Wizards like a hermit's hat as
in a wizard's hat the reason why I think he's
one of the blue Wizards is just because in the
Canon one of the blue Wizards went to roon and
we just haven't explored that in the books that
much or in any of the movies which is why I
think that they thought that it was plumbed
to include in the series like oh we haven't done
that before let's just put it in here the harpists
try to rescue him and then he winds up trying to
rescue them remembering a little bit about who
he is he doesn't remember everything but like he
remembers how to speak well like he can actually
speak regular sentences and he remembers how to
use some of his power like he takes their staff
and sends them back to the Unseen realm that's
basically what's happening here that's why for
a brief second they look kind of like the nozzle
like their Spirits here are basically being blown
back into the Unseen realm the whole thing with
the butterflies I think is meant to be a callback
to the fireworks Gandalf used during the Lord of
the Rings movies looking kind of like butterflies
also in the Canon there's a constellation created
by one of the Valor that's given the same name
that the elves use for butterflies so it could
be just another reference to him being a mire
send from a louvitar the same group of beings but
the idea is that even though he's from the is tar
they're like another subgroup of the Meyer he
is basically the same type of being that Sauron
is like they're like the same kind of power level
also all the references that the women make to him
slowly regaining his strength and remembering his
power is another parallel for Sauron it explains
why he's so weak during the events of episode
1 and he references that later when he's trying
to convince Galadriel to allow him to create the
rings of power and take over the planet like join
me at my side I'll talk about that in a second
when we get to that part of the episode because
a lot of their conversation is literally the same
conversation that Galadriel has with Frodo later
when he tries to give her the one ring of power
saddock winds up being one of the big casualties
of the finale so R.I.P when we go to alendil and
Muriel talking about the faithful those are just
the group of people who believe in the Valar still
and wind up coming back to Middle Earth to fight
Sauron they're also the ones that survive the
downfall of numenor and wind up creating Gondor
even though there's still lots of questions
about what happened to isildur obviously he's
very critical he's not dead like they're not going
to kill him off because he's so important later in
the timeline he's basically like Aragorn's great
great great great grandfather many times removed
he'll probably wind up showing up during season
2 episode 1. it also seems that they're teasing a
relationship with between Allendale and Muriel
here the thing that shocks him when they get
back to numenor or the black flags in the harbor
are marking the death of her father when Sauron
suggests combining the mithril with the other ores
to stretch it out that's a reference to the title
of the episode creating alloy combining two metals
also the term stretching out as a reference to the
side effects of the Rings of power stretching out
lifespans like Bilbo says later in the timeline
butter spread out on too much toast it doesn't
give you more years on your lifespan it just
stretches out your lifespan because originally
Sauron was planning for all the rings of power
to be worn by elves who already Immortal so it's
not really an issue for them but for humans who
only live for like a hundred years it basically
just makes them live for thousands of years
theoretically which is why Gollum deteriorates
the way that he does because his body just wasn't
meant to survive that long when he says precious
metals were scarce in the place he came up in he's
talking about the place before creation like the
void of nothingness and when he says his idea to
Celebrimbor is a gift that's a reference to his
annatar name came from the books which literally
means Lord of gifts back on numenor pharazon talks
about the impending death of the former King,
Muriel's father seems like he's putting his plans
into motion just leading up to the downfall they
tease this a lot through isildur's sister as well
when she finds the palantir but I think the whole
idea here is that that's such a big thing they're
probably going to save it for like season three
like maybe like a cliffhanger ending for season
three WTF moment his sister's chosen as one of
the draftsmen to design his Monument after he dies
when he grabs certain whispers about knowing what
she's done in the dark of night he's talking
about what Soren was doing when he was using
the palantir himself because he also says he gets
confused because he's stared into it for too long
so he confuses the past the present in the future
so the entire timeline to him is this jumble of
images without any context but he continues
talking to her thinking that she's Muriel
talking about the Doom of numenor that's what
he means when he says they have to restore the
old ways or the island will fall like literally it
will fall into the ocean it's called the downfall
for a couple reasons but like it's a metaphor and
a literal thing and even though they don't show
show us what she sees in the palantir I think the
idea is that she's supposed to see the same thing
that Galadriel and that Miro saw which is the
Doom itself and at the beginning of season two
she'll wind up telling her father about that like
I saw something crazy in the palantir then when
we go back to gilgallot he talks about having one
object for all of Middle Earth that's him talking
about the one ring of power one ring to rule them
all but like I said they want to tease this out
through the episode like they go through a couple
different iterations of their idea like should
it be a crown One Crown no two things what about
three things he says the blight accelerated after
the eruption of Mount Doom and when Celebrimbor
says that Halbrand or sauron's suggestions were
the key that unlocked the damn that's really what
makes things click in galadriel's mind like right
after that he says not of flesh but over flesh
and mentions the Unseen World and those are all
things that are said during the Lord of the Rings
movies about the one ring of power and the whole
idea with Galadriel at least canonically in the
books is that she was never fooled by Sauron she
knew exactly what was up with him the whole
time and that's basically what happens during
this episode like immediately once he starts
pushing for the creation of the Rings that of
power she realizes exactly what's happening like
bursting of a dam didn't I just see a giant damn
burst and then set off Mountain doom and this
giant eruption oh something's up here the Unseen
World mention is also a callback to her seeing
sauron's Forge in episode 1 in their Fortress
when Gil Gallard references elrond not being owed
anything that's just a reference to what happened
with his deception in the doors the mithril his
comment about Hope is a reference to his speech
that he'll eventually have with the hobbits during
the Lord of the Rings movies later in the timeline
like meager small Hobbits small loved all the
Montage scenes of them actually in Celebrimbor's
Forge creating the rings of power like you see
halbrand kind of like pushing him talking in the
background just kind of subtly influencing him
like what if we try these things the whole idea
here is that he had to make Celebrimbor feel
like all this stuff was his idea otherwise it
wouldn't have worked here's the whole thing with
the genealogy chart in the line of Kings and the
Southlands initially Galadriel just wants to prove
that Halbrand isn't who he says he is he's really
Sauron but when elrond finds it at the end of the
episode and starts freaking out I think they'll
reveal that Thea is actually the true heir of the
last king of the Southlands like there is an air
but it's Theo because he has this mystery father
that they still haven't paid off yet and it just
seems like a really big Arc for his character like
they were teasing him potentially becoming evil
but I think they want to tease Redemption for him
eventually like you are the line of Kings you have
a chance to save these people also the funny thing
with the King references is you remember the old
man like the old man was right the whole time he
kept talking about their true king returning but
he said that that was Sauron and that's basically
the way things played out in the show like yes I
am your true king as he's talking to the other
southlanders he is a king of men he is the king
of this area but not the one you thought you were
getting his whole speech with Galadriel about not
believing someone like him would ever be in this
Elven city is just another callback to the war
of Wrath and what happened with the words before
that before the war of Wrath like that was like
the last big war with morgoth the one where the
Valar eventually got involved so the elves would
Slaughter him on site if they knew that it was
him which is why he's so amazed that he's walking
around like wow it's so amazing that I could just
walk around in broad daylight nobody kills me he
makes all these references to Galadriel being
the one to save him him giving up hope until
she helped him find it again obviously he has a
much darker connotation now and I think that he's
being true like I think that he Sauron had kind
of given up on his grand plan until he happened
upon Galadriel and just used the opportunity and
now Galadriel will just carry the guilt of that
going forward into the third age for thousands of
years I was the one who convinced Sauron that he
could carry on with his plan to conquer the world
there's his real special connection that they're
forging between the two of them on the show that
we don't really see in The Lord of the Rings
movies but the whole idea here is he's still at
a fraction of his power like you see him use some
of his power when he enters galadriel's mind and
messes with some of her memories and her brother
and physically he's able to stop her because elves
are way stronger than normal humans basically what
happened according to the show like the reason why
he's so weak now why he lost hope so to speak is
because Adar says that he killed him but because
the mayor are Immortal beings you can't actually
destroy their Spirits eventually their spirits
will coalesce and they'll be able to form a new
body again which he did in the Halbrand body but
like the wizard when he first lands on Middle
Earth like he first enters this physical form
they're in a very weakened State and it takes
them time to amass their full power again that's
what happened with Sauron after Adar killed him
like he eventually he formed another body which is
the halbrand body that we see walking around here
he lost some of his memories and most of his power
but over time it just slowly all came back to him
like by the events of this episode he remembers
everything about his past and he's got some of
his power probably still has a little ways to go
before he's at full power again this also happens
later in the timeline during the downfall
of numador like he's on numenor during the
downfall in his body is destroyed so he resurrects
again because he's a mayor he's Immortal but he
resurrects at a fraction of his power and he can't
change form anymore like he's severely weakened
which is why you always see him walking around in
the giant armor during later the timeline in the
third age something similar to this happened to
morgoth but in a slightly different way the whole
idea is that the Valar and the mayor have a finite
level of power now it's crazy power and The Valor
are more powerful than the mayor if he thought
that Sauron was like this crazy powerful evil
person more goth is like 10 times more powerful
than he is but during the show when they keep
referencing the blight that's affecting Linden
that will eventually fall over the entire planet
like this Shadow Of Darkness that's falling over
the planet the Sauron tells Galadriel that he's
going to stop like I will save the world and it
will redeem me in the eyes of a louvitar it's all
a reference to morgoth literally pouring his dark
power into the planet to darken to change it what
ended up happening during the first stage before
he was defeated is that he poured too much of
his power into the planet and it weakened him so
much that he was basically trapped on Middle Earth
you'd have to imagine like an angel being weakened
to the point where it couldn't leave its physical
form anymore that's what happened to morgoth and
eventually what happens to Sauron when he admits
to finding the crest on a dead man he's talking
about the last king from a thousand years ago from
the Southlands during the war of Wrath like he's
saying that he found it on the last king because
he killed the last king I killed him then I took
it from his body he also reminds us that Adar is
his enemy like I fought beside you against our
enemy yours and mine a reference to him sticking
it to Adar getting revenge for Adar killing
him thousands of years ago and when he says
he's been awake since before the breaking of the
first silence he's talking about the time before
creation itself so at the beginning of the Lord of
the Rings timeline aluvitar creates The Valor of
the Meyer and they sing creation into existence
and that includes the planet they refer to that
song of creation as the great song so like that's
them breaking the silence so it's like him saying
I've been alive since before creation itself
and when he says he's had many names in the time
he's been alive Sauron is just the more recent
name that he was given by the elves later in
the timeline in their language it just means the
abhorrid his original name that the other Maiar
called him was Mairon which just means admirable
and excellent because remember he's kind of like a
fallen angel like morgoth so originally he looked
like this he was very Angelic being but he fell
from Grace turned to evil the numenoreans also
give him the name zigger which means sorcerer he
also calls himself annatar like I said previously
when he references the gifts because annatar means
Lord of gifts he was also called artano which
means hi Smith because his whole whole skill is
in making things and the other big name he was
called by was al-lendale which means friend of
Aule the Smith the person that he studied under
then using his power which he's amassed enough
of he's able to enter her mind and manipulate
her memories taking her to this memory from the
prologue in episode one of her childhood talking
to her brother but it's him manipulating all these
scenes so he's the one that's speaking even
though you're hearing her brother's voice in
all these scenes are him trying to win her to his
cause when he references filling the light of the
one again he's talking about a louvitar because
morgoth darkened all of his followers including
Sauron literally and metaphorically like Twisted
them to evil so a louvitar's light is metaphorical
and literal is also a callback to the light of
the lamps and then to the two trees in the same
light coming from the mithril and all these scenes
are then basically trying to create a more complex
characterization for Sauron and it's like a Walter
White Breaking Bad kind of version of Sauron where
he believes that he's doing something good but he
winds up doing terrible things in the process and
is a slippery slope and he slowly does worse and
worse things until he's full-blown evil the show
Runners during season two even said they're doing
like a Walter White version of Sauron and I think
their reference is more to late era Walter White
like not Walter White at the beginning of the
Breaking Bad story but like Walter White later
in the story right before he gets to the point
where he says I am the danger in the way he tries
to sell her on this is that he's doing all this
to help bring peace to the world but the idea is
that it's his peace through his Force like he'll
rule the world and bring it peace or it'll bring
it death the Iron Fist of peace and I think the
idea is that he's meant to believe that in doing
that in healing the world with his forced piece
like whatever he calls peace he thinks that'll
win him forgiveness from a louvitar obviously
probably not going to happen because like even
later in the timeline after they kill him because
you can't kill someone in a traditional sense
because he's a Maiar once the one ring of power
is destroyed his Spirit basically dissipates
to a level where it's so near zero he'll never
be able to bring his form together and reform
another physical body so essentially he's no
longer a threat but he's still technically
not dead when he shows the vision of them
standing side by side and he starts talking to her
about becoming his Queen this speech is basically
exactly what she says to Frodo later and now
with the added context it's like she's actually
remembering that when Frodo offered sort of the
One Ring of Power when elrond rescues Galadriel
from the river she calls him deceiver that's
what she called Sauron later Sauron the deceiver
but they were all of them deceived when he says
the first time they met was when he was first
orphaned that was in Valerian here before it was
sank in the war of Wrath and he was being raised
by the enemy so to speak like one of the sons of
Theodore which basically killed his father and
then led to the death of his mother then Sauron
takes off we see him at the end of the episode
showing up in front of Mordor Mount Doom getting
ready to create the rest of the Rings of power and
the One Ring of Power I think the whole idea is
that he'll create the other lesser Rings first and
offer them to the dwarves into the humans and then
he'll create the One Ring of Power like that'll be
the end of season 2 Season 3. we'll see how fast
they blow through the timeline like how many rings
are going to be flying around by the end of season
two in all the references that Galadriel makes to
Celebrimbor about the power being for them alone
like we need to create a power that's separate
just for the elves that's a reference to the
relationship of these rings of power to the other
rings of power like I said because they weren't
touched by Sauron they were also protected from
saron's influence when he created the One Ring
they also melt down her brother's dagger like I
said I think that's also metaphorically meant to
be her slowly adopting a more peaceful stance when
we go back to the wizard he literally uses the
name is tar as an is tari their subgroup of Mayor
but they're all still mayor so he's just like
Sauron is Nori going with him and then heading
to roon is their way of basically telling you that
most of season 2's hard foot story will just be
through her character but they might bring some
of the other hard foots back eventually when he
references the path laid out for them by greater
Powers it's a reference to a louvitar sending him
to Middle Earth in this physical form with the
task of helping them stop Sauron alumitar also
did the exact same thing later in the timeline
with Gandalf and the other istari like Saruman and
radagast and during Two Towers when Gandalf was
resurrected as Gandalf the White essentially what
happened because you can't kill mayor his Spirit
just went back to where it came from in a louvitar
kind of turned it around on its way and sent him
back to Middle Earth you have to imagine Gandalf's
Cosmic Soul screaming through outer space is the
place where oluvitar lives and luvitar reaching
out with a giant finger and just turning his
path around so that he screams back to Middle
Earth typically a louvitar wouldn't do stuff like
that for just anybody the reason why he did it for
Gandalf is because his task that he had given him
wasn't complete yet they hadn't destroyed the One
Ring of Power yet when he starts talking about
adventures and Journeys it's another callback to
the actual Fellowship of the Ring when we go back
to Celebrimbor's Forge they finished crafting the
Elven rings of power when elrond drops the mithril
piece into the melting ore pot here it's made to
look like the eye of Sauron again just like the
meteor impact site is meant to look like the eye
of Sauron so just lots of references to the eye
of Sauron throughout the series we'll probably
see even more of that during season two I already
explained which of these rings are who they go
to what their special powers are earlier in the
video and I also already explained what's going
on with elrond in this tag scene at the end where
he grabs the document about the genealogy of the
line of kings in the Southlands like I said I
think this is going to be about Theo being the
true heir to the last king and we end the episode
with Sauron looking at Mount Doom preparing to
create the other rings of power in the One Ring
of Power with them then singing the song from the
books about the creation of all the Rings which
is actually pretty cool song I love the way they
use that over the credits the showrunner said that
during season two Sauron will be walking around in
his fair form now they said that last week I think
we what they meant is is that they'll be walking
around looking like Halbrand this whole time but
eventually at some point during the series he'll
put his armor back on but for the most part you'll
see him walking around without the armor on like
they want you to see his face also because Adar
is still alive I think they'll have a big battle
between Sauron and Adar like another rematch well
Sarah will wind up killing him and that'll just be
his way of taking control of Mordor if there's any
other Easter eggs and references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
them Below in the comments and also let me know
which wizard do you think that Meteor Man is is
he one of the blue Wizards or is he going to be
some other character from the Canon my Full House
of the Dragon Episode 9 video will post on Sunday
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my house
of the Dragon episode 9 video and everyone click
here for my House of the Dragon episode 8 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one foreign!